[Musik]
kannst du die ein land vorstellen in den
klassen mit salzwasser bewässert werden
ein land das es geschafft hat eine
trockene unfruchtbare wüste in üppige
ackerflächen zu verwandeln ein land das
es trotz seiner lage in einer der
trockensten und dursten regionen der
erde gelungen ist über eine fast ohne
begrenzten vorrat an wasser zu verfügen
nun dies alles ist keine fata morgana
eines verdursten der wüste dieser ort
existiert tatsächlich einen großen teil
seines territoriums bilden die negev und
die jüdische müsste und ihr habt sicher
schon erraten dieses gelobte land wird
israel genannt
wir sprechen über den einzigen start auf
dem planeten erde der heute weniger
wüssten fläche hat als vor 50 jahren
denn überall sonst wachsen die hüften
ungebremst darüber hinaus exportiert
israel jedes jahr landwirtschaftliche
produkte im wert von mehr als zwei
milliarden us dollar vor allem
frischwaren wie obst und gemüse ins
ausland deswegen werden wir in diesem
video darüber sprechen
die israel dieses wunder geschafft hat
wie es die und basta wüste in einem
obstgarten einen garten eben verwandeln
und die notorische wasserknappheit
überwinden konnte lasst uns also schnell
loslegen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
bereits ein vertraulicher bericht des us
national intelligence kommt aus dem jahr
2012 der täter teilweise freigegeben
wurde wies auf die zukünftige
wasserkrise in eine gewaltige globale
krise der wasserverband diesen bericht
zufolge liegt der wasserverbrauch
jenseits jeder nachhaltigen form des
wirtschaftens es gibt immer mehr von uns
und wir verbrauchen immer mehr und mehr
konsumieren mehr fleisch haben mehr
gärten mehr mit puls verbrauchern in
einem energie und kaufen internet
produkte bei deren herstellung unmengen
von wasser verbraucht werden und dass
wir dies im grunde wissen müssen zb wird
für die herstellung von einem kilogramm
fleisch 17 mal so viel wasser benötigt
wie für die eines kilos mais der bericht
bestätigte die ergebnisse vieler
experten wonach mehr als 20 prozent der
weltbevölkerung mehr als 1,5 milliarden
menschen in den kunden jahrzehnten unter
starker wachsamkeit zu leiden haben
werden das sind 1,5 milliarden menschen
die ernste sehr ernste probleme mit den
zugang zu einer regelmäßigen
wasserförderung haben werden wir
sprechen hier von einer krise welche die
gesamte globale nahrungsmittelversorgung
bedrohen kann und glaubt bitte nicht
einen moment daran dass sie nur die
ärmsten länder betreffen wird zum
beispiel könnte das trikot rki in berlin
in kalifornien das kern lang der
kalifornischen qualitäts landwirtschaft
verschwinden zumindest in der form in
der wir es heute kennen
diese waren und kat rust zur
schlüsselfrage diese videos geführt sind
wir wirklich alle zu wasserknappheit und
den damit verbundenen katastrophalen
auswirkungen verdammt oder gibt es eine
lösung dieses problems nun ich denke es
ist an der zeit hier zu einen blick auf
eine der trockensten und fruchtbarsten
worte des planeten zu werfen
[Musik]
nicht weniger als 60 prozent des
israelischen staatsgebiets ist von
wüsten bedeckt deswegen haben israelis
eine sehr enge beziehung zum wasser das
thema wasser ist ständig präsent 2 das
in kultur politik oder gar der
religionen tatsächlich war und eines der
bekanntesten jüdischen bete dass
schneider vor dass die strafen für die
nichterfüllung von gottes geboten
insbesondere darin besteht dass der
regen aufhört zu fallen und trotz alldem
ist israel wie ihr vielleicht wisst ein
wohlhabendes land ein großer
agrarexporteure der über eine reichliche
und garantierte wasserversorgung verfügt
in der tat nicht sogar eine menge der
lebensspendenden flüssigkeit an seinen
nachbarn die große frage die uns also
stellen müssen lautet wie in aller welt
haben es die israelis geschafft die
wasserknappheit zu überwinden
was können andere länder von israel
lernen wird uns das know how aus israel
vor einem brutalen zeitalter des durstes
retten
in diesem video werden alle diese fragen
beantworten aber zuerst müssen wir uns
kurz mit ein wenig geschichte
beschäftigen
[Musik]
die akte riehen israels
in den späten 1920 er jahren erklärten
wirtschaftswissenschaftler berater der
britischen regierung welche damals
dieses gebiet kontrolliert dass die
einwanderung von juden nach palästina
nicht nachhaltig sei denn ihren
berechnungen und modell zufolge waren
die wasservorkommen so begrüßt das ist
unmöglich war mehr als zwei millionen
menschen in diesem gebiet zu versorgen
heute leben dort aber mehr als 14
millionen und das mit üppiger
wasserversorgung
tja mit experten die ihr geld durch
reißerische angst prognose verdienen
dürfen wir ja immer noch regelmäßig
unsere erfahrungen machen tatsache ist
jedoch dass die jüdischen organisation
in der region von diesem moment an
verstanden hat dass ihre ganze zukunft
von wasser abhängig
sie mussten die versorgung um jeden
preis sicherstellen die neuen siedler
die kommen würden um ein neues israel
mit neuer landwirtschaft aufzubauen
doch natürlich stand ihnen dabei ein
gewaltiges problem im weg der größte
teil des landes waren nichts als wüste
absolut trocken und unfruchtbar die
verfügbaren wasserressourcen
konzentrierten sich vor allem im norden
aber die jugend siedelte sich vor allem
um die neue großstadt tel aviv an die in
der landesmitte liegt es war es in kabul
ein polnischer einwanderer der im jahr
1931 als einer der renommiertesten
wasserbauingenieur damit beauftragt
wurde einen zukunftsplan für die
wasserversorgung zu entwerfen
es sollte sich um nichts geringeres
handeln als um den masterplan der
israels zukunft garantieren sollte und
weißt du was
das sollte sich als goldrichtige wahl
entpuppen mit alles an dem
einfallsreichtum und wagemut seinen drei
phasen plan der im grunde genommen über
jahrzehnte hinweg israels demografischen
und wirtschaftlichen aufschwung
ermöglicht die erste phase bestand darin
wasser durch das bohren von
tiefenbohrlöcher extra hier sind platz
war davon überzeugt dass ist unter dem
untergrund israels selbst in so
trockenen gebieten wie der negev-wüste
wasser gibt also machte er sich auf den
weg um es zu finden und so die gründung
neuer farben zu ermöglichen natürlich
würde eine solche operation selbst wenn
sie erfolgreich wäre nicht ausreichen
das land würde jeden verfügbaren tropfen
des kostbaren nass ist optimal nutzen
müssen das heißt vor allem das wasser
von dort wo es reichlich vorhanden war
dorthin zu bringen wo es am meisten
gebraucht wurde genau aus diesem grund
standen die nächsten beiden phasen ganz
im zeichen dieser idee
[Musik]
die zweite phase zielte darauf ab was am
jordan den wichtigsten fluss in der
region in den südosten zu pumpen ja
sogar bis in dem der gäste damals
unbewohntes gebiet welches besiedelt und
landwirtschaftlich urbar gemacht werden
sollte
aber wer bei weitem bedeutendste teil
des plans war die dritte phase der bau
des nationalen credo der sprechen von
einer imposanten wasserleitung von mehr
als 100 kilometer länge die wasser aus
dem norden des landes vor allem aus dem
see genezareth den größten süßwassersee
israels dorthin bringen sollte wo es
gebraucht wird und dabei auch die in den
vorherigen erschlossenen ressourcen
miteinander verbindet mit anderen worten
was ist den gast vorschlug war ein
riesiger investitionsplan um die
arterien israels zu schaffen ein
riesiges wasser verteilungssystem das
den zugang zu frischem wasser im ganzen
land garantieren würde
und eines sollte klar sein die zeit zur
umsetzung dieses plans drängte
[Musik]
am tag der unabhängigkeitserklärung des
jüdischen staates und vierzehnten mal
1988 hatte israel 800 6000 einwohner
dann innerhalb der drei jahre kamen fast
700.000 weitere menschen ins land
die meisten davon aus europa um so
plötzlich so viele menschen versorgen zu
können sie zu ernähren und ihnen dabei
zu helfen arbeit zu finden damit sie
sich damit selbst versorgen können
brauchte man natürlich sehr viel wasser
die rationierung von wasser wurde immer
prekärer und die umsetzung des plans
wurde ein angelegenheit höchster
dringlichkeit das nächste problem war
aber dass das alles sehr viel geld
kosten würde und israel damals alles
andere als reich war erst zu schweigen
davon dass die wenig ressourcen die der
junge israelische regierung zur
verfügung statt größtenteils in
sicherheit und verteidigung floss denn
das junge land wurde gleich nach seiner
gründung von den nachbarn angegriffen
die ist wieder auslöschen wollten die
frage lautet also woher nehmen und nicht
stehlen hierzu traf der damalige
premierminister israels ben gurion eine
der umstrittensten entscheidungen in der
geschichte des landes eine entscheidung
die am ende sogar zu einem bürgerkrieg
führen können
[Musik]
in den frühen 50er jahren gab ben gurion
sein einverständnis zur unterzeichnung
eines reparationen abkommens mit konrad
adenauers bundesrepublik deutschland ein
abkommen durch dass der staat israel
eine entschädigung von drei milliarden
d-mark als ausgleich für die verbrechen
der nazis und den diebstahl und die
zerstörung jüdischen eigentums während
der zeit des dritten reiches erhielt nun
musst du aber verstehen dieses abkommen
bei sehr vielen israel ist ungeheuer
unpopulär
ein regelrechter affront ein abkommen
mit dem land in dem die raubmörder ihrer
familienangehörigen und freunde leben
die konnte man überhaupt eine
entschädigung für so viel nicht zu
entschädigenden schaden und schmerz
akzeptieren viele israelis hatten das
gefühl dass die apokalyptischen slide
verkauft wurde
das eines der tragischsten ereignis in
der geschichte der menschheit zur ware
gemacht wurde es kam zu protesten
demonstration und gewaltsamen
zusammenstößen mit sicherheitskräften
am ende nahmen die knesset das
israelische parlament das abkommen mit
einer mehrheit von nur zwei stimmen an
[Musik]
das geld war da die umleitung des jordan
flusses wurde 1955 gestellt und in den
nächsten jahren wurde das land quasi auf
den kopf gestellt das nationale athen
hatte den bau von rohren kanälen und
klein reservoirs im ganzen land das
haupt netzwerk selbst musste im grunde
unterirdisch verlaufen mit jedem angriff
stand halten zu können
tausende und abertausende von menschen
arbeiteten an diesem mammutprojekt und
die pro kopf ausgaben überstiegen selbst
die des panamakanals eines weiteren
jahrhundertprojekt doch schließlich 1964
war das nationale aquädukt realität
geworden die wasserversorgung war
eigentlich im ganzen land gewährleistet
heute können wir mit sicherheit sagen
dass ohne die damaligen immensen
anstrengungen das enorme wirtschaftliche
und demographische wachstum israels
nicht möglich gewesen wäre
allerdings verfügt das land heute über
mehr als neun millionen einwohner und
eine moderne wirtschaft also muss heute
mehr getan werden vielmehr also
aufgepasst denn jetzt wirds erst richtig
spannend
[Musik]
mehr wasser aus meerwasser
der beginn des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts brachte die probleme mit
der wasserversorgung wieder auf die
tagesordnung
und diesmal würde nicht weniger als eine
ganz neue revolution in gang gesetzt
schau mal im jahr 2006 wurde die
entscheidung getroffen das management
ist was das systems wo der politischen
auf die technokratische ebene zu
übertragen das heißt die politiker
würden nicht mehr das sagen haben die is
what i wurde gegründet eine behörde
deren aufgabe es ist das system
professionell zu verwalten und genau das
haben sie auch getan
im jahr 2008 traf die wasserbehörde eine
sehr kontroverse entscheidung jeder
sollte die tatsächlichen kosten für die
bereitstellung von wasser bezahlen
bis dahin wurde wie in den meisten
ländern der welt der wasserpreis von der
regierung subventionierte die menschen
verstehen dass wasser ein schatz ist
aber sie verstehen nicht warum sie dafür
bezahlen müssen sie sehen regen und
denken wasser seien kostenlos und sie
haben recht das wasser ist kostenlos
aber sicheres zuverlässiges immer
verfügbares wasser ist nicht kostenlos
und kann nicht kostenlos sein
die infrastruktur ist nicht kostenlos
diese maßnahme hatte zwei ganz klare
ziele zum einen sollte das bausparen
gefördert werden denn er mehr bezahlen
muss verbraucht gut verschwendet weniger
zum anderen sollte mit den mehreinnahmen
der ausbau der infrastruktur
vorangetrieben und die erwartung
verbessert werden
aber das war noch nicht alles diese
agentur übernahm und den gemeinden auf
die kontrolle über die wasserverteilung
und das abwassermanagement im gegenzug
schoss sie als system von 55 kommunalen
unternehmen die nach markt kriterien
arbeiten mussten um das gesamte netz zu
verwalten die eingenommenen gebühren
würden nicht mehr in die kommunalen
haushalte fließen sondern ausschließlich
in die verbesserung des systems zb um
wasser lecks in den leitungen zu
minimieren
denn diese führen den allgemeinen in
vielen ländern zu einem verlust von mehr
als 30 prozent des wassers im falle
israels liegt die verlustquote nun
deutlich unter zehn prozent wenn also
ein bürgermeister die städtischen parks
verbessern will bekommt er das was hat
das nun nicht mehr umsonst sondern muss
den marktpreis die tatsächlichen kosten
tja und was denkt ihr was diese
ökonomische maßnahme ein erfolg ja und
zwar ein ganz und gar durchschlagender
erfolg ohne das reale angebot für die
menschen einschränken zu müssen sagt der
wasserverbrauch der öffentlichen und
privaten haushalte landesweit um fast 20
prozent aufgrund des finanziellen drucks
wurden zum beispiel in parks und gärten
viele pflanzen durch arten ersetzt die
besser an die umgebungsbedingungen
angepasst sind und weniger wasser
verbrauchen in der landwirtschaft
geschah das gleiche
aber das ist noch nicht alles um die
innovationsfreude israelis beim thema
was hast du bevor er nicht hat die
regierung förderprogramme für
investitionen in neue wassertechnologie
unternehmen aufgelegt die idee war
israelische städte quasi in hightech
wasserlabor zu verwandeln die
unternehmen konkurrieren um die
fördergelder
während innovationen ihnen erlauben ihre
ergebnisse zu verbessern und mit diesem
gewinn wurde die dürre in den ersten
jahren dieses jahrhunderts ein weiteres
mal besiegt aber wisst ihr was das ist
noch lange nicht das ende der
israelische veranstalter denn die
israelis das üben sich nicht einfach
damit die dürre zu besiegen nein sie
wollen so viel wasser haben wie nur geht
und daraus dann ein großes business
machen und genau das hat israel auch
erreicht aufgepasst
[Applaus]
einfallsreichtum ist der schlüssel
israel ist ein land das wird drei dinge
bekannt ist seine legendären
geheimdienst mossad die effizienz seiner
streitkräfte und innovation die
weltweite spitzenklasse
in der tat ist das nützliche land als
die startup nation schlechthin bekannt
in sachen rüstung in sachen it und im
falle des wassermanagements dass eine
nationale priorität darstellt sollte
dies dann wohl auch nicht untersagen
der fokus liegt dabei auf der
landwirtschaft immerhin 55 prozent des
gesamten wasserverbrauchs in israel
darstellt es ist daher kein wunder dass
genau in diesem land wenn der großen
landwirtschaftlichen revolution der
letzten jahrzehnte stadt warnt die
tröpfchenbewässerung auf eine technik
die bis zu 60 prozent wasser sparen und
gleichzeitig die ernteerträge verbessert
wir sprechen von einer technik dann
besteht eine pflanze tropfenweise direkt
an der wurzel zu bewässern und die in
den letzten jahren mit der sogenannten
fertiger zion noch mal verbessert wurde
also dem tropfen weisen ausbringen von
dünger
durch ein bewässerungssystem wir
sprechen hier von hochgradig
kontrolliert optimierter wohl
automatisierter nährstoffzufuhr auf dem
neuesten stand der landwirtschaftlichen
technik die trifft interesse und
versorgt die pflanzen mit allem was ich
für optimales wachstum benötigen so dass
sogar riesige plantagen auf bloßen sand
mitten in der wüste entstehen können mit
nährstoff bewässerung wachsen die
klassen überall müssten dann kann
verwendet werden um die pflanze an ort
und stelle zu halten und nährstoff
wasser wird durch trotz der westbank
verabreicht die dann den rest erledigt
winzige sensoren die an den gewürzen
angebracht werden erkennen wann genau
die pflanze gegossen und mit welchen
nährstoffen versorgt werden muss sie
steuern sogleich das verteilungssystem
so dass quasi jede pflanze individuell
gibt überträgt und natürlich wurde all
diese technologie hauptsächlich von
israelischen unternehmen entwickelt aber
das ist noch nicht alles
ein weiterer bereich in dem israelis
besonders gut sind ist saatgut sowohl
traditionelle als auch gentechnisch
verändert ist
sie haben es geschafft dadurch den
wasserverbrauch zu reduzieren und jetzt
haltet euch fest sie haben sogar saat
und entwickelt das mit leicht salzigen
wasser bewässert werden kann sich zum
beispiel brackwasser dass im gesamten
nahen osten in großen mengen im
untergrund zu finden ist wo der mann
aber immer dachte es sei vollkommen
nutzlos und ohne aufwändige aufarbeitung
für pflanzen menschen und tiere gänzlich
und genießbar
ja du hast richtig gehört in israel
castro melonen tomaten paprika
auberginen und viele andere obst- und
gemüsesorten finden die mit einem
gemisch
aus süß- und salzwasser bewässert werden
unglaublich nicht war eine wahre garten
eden aber auf er aber warte da kommt
noch was wegen der ganzen infrastruktur
die an das nationale produkte angebunden
ist hat dieses land in den letzten
jahren eine zweite parallele
infrastruktur entwickelt und reinigt das
abwasser im ganzen land zu sammeln und
wieder zu verteilen so dass nicht
weniger als 85 prozent des gesamten
absatzes wiederverwendet werden
hauptsächlich in der landwirtschaft und
auch zu verbesserungen zum beispiel von
parkplätzen und öffentlichen grünanlagen
da geht quasi kein tropfen verloren und
glaubt mir so was gibt es in diesem
maßstab sonst nirgendwo auf der welt und
als wenn das nicht schon genug wäre ist
real auch noch zum weltmarktführer and
der entsalzung technologie geworden
tatsächlich befindet sich eine der
größten anlagen der welt in bezug auf
volumen und effizienz in der gegend und
tel aviv die zurück anlage ist in der
lage mehr als 600 millionen liter wasser
pro tag zu verarbeiten
auf diese weise durch eine vielzahl
gezielte und hochintelligente maßnahmen
hat israel jede dürre welche diese
weltregionen seit jahrtausenden geplagt
hat ein für alle mal überwunden israel
ein land das auf trockensten dürren und
fruchtbaren gegründet wurde hat jetzt
alles wasser das es jemals brauchen
könnte
und es liefert das kostbare nass sogar
an seine nachbarn nach gaza ins
westjordanland und auch ist königreich
jordanien aber auch darüber hinaus
bietet israel sein umfassendes know how
und entwicklungshilfe an um den menschen
in die regionen weltweit zu helfen all
dies konnte es dann überlegen der
technik innovation und auch ganz wichtig
durch wirtschaftliche anreize wie zum
beispiel ein faires und transparentes
preissystem erreichen so meine lieben
zuschauer das war die geschichte eines
winzigen landes im nahen osten welches
aus der not eine tugend machte und die
wüste im paradies auf erden einen
regelrechten garten eden verwandelte
ohne die innovationskraft des jüdischen
volks wäre der schmalen landstreifen
relevante heute wohl noch immer eine
unfruchtbare trockene hölle aber was
hältst du von israels engagement in
puncto wasserversorgung denkst du das
ist der richtige weg ist um der das sagt
heute weltweit zu begegnen
dürrekatastrophen nahrungsmittel
krankheit solchen und dadurch
verursachte armut und migrationswellen
zu verhindern ist israel der messias des
wassers der die menschheit von der dürre
erlösen kann welche anderen länder
sollten
die an seine vorbild orientieren heißt
eure meinungen bitte im kommentarbereich
mit uns und auch allen anderen ich hoffe
dass euch dieses video gefallen hat das
jahr geht uns bitte einen lag teils mit
euren freunden und vergesst nicht
unseren kanal zu abonnieren macht
gottschalk und bis bald
[Musik]